Speaker 1: one of Donald Trump's favorite
economists, made the argument on Fox News this
week that there are people like minorities who
simply aren't worth the fifteen dollars per hour
minimum wage that many on the left are advocating
for right now. I'm talking about Art Laffer. Art
Laffer is the guy after whom the Laffer Curve is
named. This is the relationship between the rate
of taxation and total government tax revenue. The
idea is if government tax the tax rate is zero,
then the government takes in no tax revenue. If
the tax rate is 100, the government also takes
in no tax revenue because why would anyone do any
work if all of your money goes to taxes? So then
once you understand that, you can find some
point on the curve that maximizes government tax
revenue. Laffer is view as a supply sider. Is that
to maximize tax revenue, you go with a lower tax
because people are more productive and therefore
government revenue goes up. He's the concept is a
fair concept. The way that Laffer applies, it
applies his own economic views to it doesn't
really make any sense. Now, Trump loves this guy.
Lots of right wingers love this. I love this guy.
So he goes on Fox News on Tuesday to argue there
are poor people and marginalized people and people
of color that just aren't worth fifteen dollars
an hour. And look at how casually he says this.
Speaker 3: OK, Austin wants to talk
about the current McDonald's CEO,
Kazinsky. He's noting that artificial intelligence
technology has eighty five percent accuracy with
filling orders with workers having to step in for
approximately one in five orders. It's going to be
a big leap, he says, to go from ten restaurants
to fourteen thousand restaurants. But there is
no doubt they are working in that direction Art.
Speaker 4: Yeah, for those people, Sandra, who are
coming into the labor force brand fresh, not old
timers who've been around for a while, the poor,
the minorities, the disenfranchized, those
with less education, young people who haven't
had the job experience. These people aren't
worth fifteen dollars an hour in most cases.
And so therefore, when you have a fifteen dollars
an hour minimum wage, they don't get that first
job. They don't get the requisite skills to earn
above the minimum wage. And after a few years
they become unemployable and after becoming
unemployable, they become hostile. And that's
what you'll find happening is this technology
has created an underclass of people who are
really just bid out of the labor market and will
remain out of the labor market for most of their
lives. And this is, I think is just a tragedy.
Speaker 1: So I understand he's not listing a
combination of traits. He's not saying, you know,
people who are poor and disenfranchized and less
educated, who are disproportionately minorities in
the country because of these historical reasons,
that would be bad enough to say they're not
worth fifteen dollars an hour. He's just saying
people from groups like these people, like
the young, aren't worth fifteen dollars an
hour. People like the uneducated aren't
worth fifteen dollars an hour. People
like minorities aren't worth fifteen dollars an
hour. It's a total mask off moment for this guy.
If you want to argue that in some low cost
of living states, there are some jobs where
fifteen dollars an hour doesn't make sense based
on the simplicity and the transience of the job,
we can talk about it. I'll probably disagree with
you, but maybe not. But that's a real conversation
that we can have. But to say lots of minorities
just aren't worth fifteen bucks an hour.
That's another level, guys. That's on another
level altogether. And while we're at it,
why is being poor a sign that you're not
worth fifteen dollars per hour if you have
the skill that the job requires and the wage
is fifteen dollars per hour in the market,
then why would your preexisting economic status,
whether you're poor or rich, why would that make a
difference? It's nuts. And if we decide that human
labor is to be compensated in a dignified way at
fifteen dollars per hour, why does coming into the
job poor make you less worthy of that wage? It's
all in completely insane. And the other aspect of
this is that if we accept some or all of Laffer,
his argument, he's making a really strong. As for
universal basic income, I don't think he knows it,
the context of this segment was automation.
Automation and technology is going to start by
taking out fifteen dollars an hour jobs, but then
it's going to start taking out twenty dollar an
hour jobs and then other jobs as technology
develops. If that is really his argument,
then why not a universal basic income? And then
one other aspect to this, in lots of places,
even 15 dollar an hour, jobs aren't being
filled right now. Now, I think it's going to be
temporary. The enhanced unemployment that's ending
in September is a factor. We have a sort of unique
circumstance right now in the aftermath or as we
start exiting the pandemic. I think by September,
people are going to need jobs and they're going
to be filled. But this is also a signal that in
some cases, 15 bucks an hour is too low. He either
doesn't get it or doesn't want to acknowledge that
all of their arguments economically depend on
these simplistic one size fits all principles.
Hey, it's your money. Why would the government
tax you? That's theft. That's a really simple
principle. Simplicity plays well with a
lot of people, but it doesn't encompass
the complexity of the real world. And so do
so do these ideas here. And then, of course,
it's the dehumanizing language. The people aren't
worth fifteen dollars per hour rather than these
jobs don't justify a fifty dollar an hour wage. I
know it's a it's a minor thing, but it gives you
a little bit of insight into how these people
view other people. Just a disgusting person.
And Fox News just welcomes him with open
arms. The host didn't even bat an eyelash
when he dropped this in there. We'll have
more from this Art Laffer appearance on
The David Pakman Show Instagram, which I
hope you're following at David Pakman show.